they're not just propagandizing in the
present progressives are also rewriting
the past not just the details not just
some characters in the past that they're
going to tweak a little bit
they are rewriting them the fundamental
purpose of the American Revolution
and they're winning pule at surprises
for it New York Times just won a
Pulitzer Prize and the Pulitzer Prize
came for its reporting on the 16:19
project 1619 project traces American
history back to the arrival of the first
African slave in the American colonies
now even the history of how slavery
developed in the American colonies is a
complex one it's not actually purely a
racial thing as the New York Times would
have you believed but that's not it look
what we're not even getting into the
details here we're just talking about
the fundamental premise the piece that
won them the Pulitzers by nicole Hannah
Jones it's called our democracies
founding ideals were false when they
were written black Americans have fought
to make them true and ironically or
perhaps not the piece that they won
their pew lats are for is fundamentally
incorrect so it begins my dad always
flew an American flag in our front yard
skip a little bit when I was young that
flag outside our home never made sense
to me how could this black man having
seen firsthand the way his country
abused black Americans how it refused to
treat them as full citizens proudly fly
its banner I didn't understand his
patriotism it deeply embarrassed me so
at least she's admitting off the top
that she hates her country right okay
got to get points for honesty here we
get to the false claim conveniently left
out of our founding mythology is the
fact that one of the primary reasons the
colonists decided to declare their
independence from Britain was because
they wanted to protect the institution
of slavery that is not true
there are many academic historians who
wrote into the New York Times to say
that that was not true in the New York
Times ignored them there is no evidence
for that whatsoever there's a lot of
evidence to the contrary
for instance in the Declaration of
Independence one of the chief complaints
against the British one of the reasons
for which they were declaring
independence is because they blamed the
British for foisting slavery on them
slavery which they detested and then of
course later on when they write the
Constitution the issue of slavery is a
big controversy because there were many
people who were drafting the
Constitution who wanted to abolish
slavery altogether there were many
people who did not want slavery to give
a reward to the south as a matter of
representation in Congress and so they
had to arrive at a compromise and they
had to sunset the importation of slaves
which they did in the Constitution and
then ultimately the inevitable Civil War
came to end slavery nothing about this
is true this was then roundly oh there's
also another false claim in here which
is pretty funny the woman who wrote it
doesn't even know when the Declaration
of Independence was signed
so initially she wrote that it was
signed on July 4th but actually the
signing began a couple weeks later on
August 2nd so or more than a couple
weeks later on August 2nd
so already you've got the Pulitzer
prize-winning essay that has multiple
Corrections right at a correction and
editors note and yet the Pulitzer
committee still gave it to them
including supporters of the 1619 project
you had lots of academic historians say
that this was trash Northwestern
University professor Leslie Harris
writes of this on August 19th of last
year I listened in stunned silence as
Nicole Hannah Jones a reporter for The
New York Times repeated an idea that I
had vigorously argued against with her
fact checker that the Patriots fought
the American Revolution in large part to
preserve slavery in America I've igger
ously disputed the claim although
slavery was certainly an issue in the
American Revolution the protection of
slavery was not one of the main reasons
the thirteen colonies went to war
so this historian and many other
historians spoke to the times about this
said guys we support the project we
support making slavery big focus when
you're writing history of America but
just as a matter of history this is not
factually correct and they ignored her
which is a pattern for the New York
Times you know in 2018 the New York
Times shared a Pulitzer Prize for its
reporting on Russia Gate which as you
might recall is a complete hoax and a
complete hoax perpetrated by the left
and the media but I repeat myself and
which is one of the reasons the
president from can't be so nice with
everybody all the time is because you've
got the entire apparatus of modern
liberalism trying to completely destroy
this man now they're trying to destroy
American history as well and it's not
just happening in the pages of the New
York Times if it were wouldn't matter
because very few people read the New
York Times but the 16:19 project is now
being taught in schools this anti
historical trash is being taught in
schools as though it were history over
the dispute ations of academic
historians who support the New York
Times who support the project but even
they are honest enough doesn't matter
this will be taught in schools and as we
were discussing yesterday on the show it
with regard to Phyllis Schlafly and the
rewriting of history on the Equal Rights
Amendment this is the kind of stuff
that's going to be remembered the
narrative is going to be remembered and
the real history increasingly is going
to be forgotten
that's why they're rewriting it in the
first place
[Music]